welcome to designing in the browser and
this seriously explore how to take a
design build it and then tweak it in the
browser using the latest and web
technology and design systems today
we're going to dive into the tools that
browsers give us to quite literally
design in them will be using chrome dev
tools and material design as our
baseline to see where we can adjust and
play let's dive in like design tools
developer tools help designers and
developers build test and debug in the
browser luckily there are a ton of great
tools and plugins that make this process
of prototyping iterating so much fun
there are tools from everything from
color selection to finessing animation
to ensuring a nice user experience on a
variety of devices and even testing load
at various network speeds dev tools help
us not only to see under the hood but to
also make changes and decisions and see
what those decisions look like in the
browser the medium in which we're
delivering the final product that's why
the series is so important as designers
we have to work in this medium and use
to our advantage to really have the most
control and power over our designs and
what's the first tool that we need
inspect element this is the primary
entry of dev tools inspect element is
often how I open up dev tools just by
left-clicking an element and finding
that inspect item in the drop down
inspect element lets you select an
elements and get information inside of
it this information includes the Cascade
of styles styles on various States
computed values classes shape and size
and more you can even change the text
content in order of the Dom of the
element within the elements panel you do
so like this so here I'm going to
left-click on this heading and hit
inspect and now I'm opening up this
information here and this is the
elements panel you can see the sizing
here is 350 pixels by 32 pixels and
Heights we have the class name here of
headlines 6 and all of the class styles
inside of that you can see here that
this Moz OSX font smoothing is not being
applied in favor of the WebKit possum
so it shows you which styles are being
applied and which ones are not being
applied we also can see here this h1 so
we're getting styles from the h1 as well
as the clasps on top of it and it shows
you which styles are being overridden
for example this font size of 2m is
being overridden in favor of a font size
of 1.25 bream with the class MVC
typography headline 6 there's also a
variety of elements that we can play
with here and I think that this is a
really great way to prototype so inside
of this if I started typing MVC
typography we get an autocomplete evolve
the different type of graphic options so
you can just sort of scroll through and
start to see what these would look like
within here so you can see that headline
one highlight two aren't actually making
a difference and that's because I still
have MVC headline six selected so you
want to uncheck that and now we can see
what the headline two looks like so if
you truly want to play with a baseline
for the styling here remove all the
classes and then start to search the
classes that are relevant to this
element so here we can see all the
typographic styles and decide which ones
makes sense this also lets you separate
your logic from your styling your logic
is the date of the text content here so
this is a header one in this form fields
element but you can apply a class on top
of it to style it however you want say
we want to style this headline one like
a headline five or headline six we can
do that and we can test that inside of
this elements panel I'm gonna select the
button now so here I'm just gonna hit
inspect on the button and it's gonna go
right to that element and we can see
that this button has a few classes as
well so right now we're using the MVC
buttons raised style but here I could
select this outline style as well and
put that in there you can play with
density inside of funds and these are
all classes that I've just sort of
playing with earlier applying them
seeing what they looked like testing
this in the browser so it's a really
powerful tool and there's a ton that you
can do by changing some of these Styles
around you can reorder things in the Dom
as well I'm gonna just scroll back into
my UI here so say we want this headline
maybe
after the paragraph we could do that
we'll probably want to change that to
being not an h1 in that case you know
make sure that you're down to like cents
but you could reorder things you could
reorder the buns you could reorder this
remember this device text there and
really to start to play with your UI in
the browser so here you could even
change the text of what the says I'm
finding this label here and now I can
change this to always Pat disco and now
I'm checking and I'm always gonna Pat
disco this is a place where you can test
different language if you're unsure how
a piece of text will fit into an element
on your screen then you can test that
and you can test this of various sizes
let's look at the color palette now in
this example we have a custom properties
based theme playground for material
design if you click to inspect the page
then we're opening up that panel and
inside the HTML you can see this route
here with all the custom properties and
their color values so here we can start
to play with what our colors look like
so if I want to change the primary theme
color I could click on that square and I
have this whole array of color here that
I can start to pick and choose and play
with and see what that looks like in my
UI maybe I want like a brake paint color
here you can also change the color type
so here's the hex code if I click on
these arrows here it changes from hex to
RGB a to hsla and speaking of alpha you
can also use this alpha toggle to toggle
the Alpha which is the amount from
transparent to full color and how much
will show through to the element behind
it so we have all of these capabilities
and another fun one is this color
palette so in this color palette we get
a base palette of colors but we can also
start to pick color from the page so you
see these page colors here where the
initial page colors these color variable
is that the dev tools have found from
the page as the most prevalent colors on
that page so if you're working within a
design and you have a palette that
you're working with you can easily find
the colors from that palette inside of
tool here there's also the CSS variables
that are being pulled out here that we
can get the color values from and we can
just start to really play with color in
this way so say I want this to be a
bright pink that sounds good
maybe we want to change the color on
that primary here we can also change
this color value we can change the we
can change the secondary color value so
we can change this to maybe a purple
value and you can start to see how this
cascades throughout the entire
application so now if I scroll through
you can see that all the secondary
values like the checkboxes the switches
this is all live code and we can see
that this is in the browser transitioned
and transformed all these elements
during pulling in those colors in the
drawer here we see a background on the
active elements and that is also pulling
from the primary color but being all but
faded behind so you can still see a
contrast with the text on top of it so
by applying these color changes in the
browser you can really see what that
looks like in various elements and in
various states of those elements so
let's go back to the top up here and
select this button what we can also do
in dev tools is figure out if something
is accessible or not which is a really
great shortcut to have so here on the
button we have a color value and a
background color value if I click on
this color value you can see that we
have a contrast ratio of 8.5 point 1
that's great if we made that color value
a little bit more closer to the
background color that contrast ratio
starts to get lower and you can see that
that's no longer accessible so we get a
lot of help here when you have a color
and background color within an element
to help us make decisions on contrast
and on colors that are accessible for
our users if we click this open we can
see where that's accessible so we can
see that's accessible for double-a for
larger text and not necessarily for
Triple A which means that we will have
to have that white value for it to be
triple a contrast accessible and for
this to work for our users make sure
that you're keeping accessibility in
mind at all times and you can
use the color palettes inside of dev
tools to help you to do that especially
when it comes to color selection and
readability on various elements let's
talk about the animations palette in
episode 1 where we talk about motion on
the web we recreated this wringing
button so let's inspect this element in
dev tools and explore what that looks
like behind the scenes so here I'm gonna
hit inspect on this button I want to
make sure that I have the button
selected here and then in the bottom
year we have this animations palette now
if you don't have this you can find it
in this drop down menu this little kebab
menu and you can hit more tools in the
drop-down and then animations is the
first item in that secondary drop-down
so that's what's gonna bring up this
animations palette for us so now inside
of here we see that we have multiple
animations happening if I click open on
those animations we can find that on the
button we have this grow animation where
it's growing over time and on the icon
inside of that button we have this ring
and I can actually toggle back and forth
between here like this is a keyframe I
can go forwards and backwards I can
pause I can play I'm gonna pull this up
a little bit here so what I can also do
is I can adjust the time stamps these
are percentage based animations so if I
wanted to make this grow really long
this will break up the effect of it
ringing as it grows but just to show you
I now have it sort of off-kilter it's
ringing its rings still sort of not
changing its size so you can start to
really break things down here I have it
ringing very tightly in this section
here I could break that up too you can
move these around so I can move it back
and forth I can have this start to grow
before I have the ring happening I'm
ruining this animation but the idea is
to show you that you can have animations
that are separate from each other and
then also test what this looks like
together so now I have it ringing off
kilter from the size changes but here if
you a lot of animations that are complex
and you have to orchestrate them
together you can take a look at what
that is
what that looks like you can take a look
at what the animations are happening
inside of this element so we have a box
shadow change to as its growing and
changing color there and then start to
play with this start to finesse in the
browser and this is a really great
opportunity for prototyping because if
things are off it's a lot easier to see
it visually than it is to try to read
the code and figure out what's a little
bit off when those time stamps are
different too if you want to slow this
down to get a little bit more of a
finesse and detail here you can also
change the speed at which your animated
so here I said 25% and I have this very
slowly now starting to grow and shake
here starting to ring very slowly so
this is another opportunity for you to
adjust speeds and see where things are
in a very precise way 10% is another
speed option for very complex animations
again you can start to really get in
there in the details and intricacies of
these animations let's talk about the
device panel now I use this tool all the
time and we're going to showcase it I've
opened up the material dot IO websites
and I'm just going to hit inspect from
any part of the page to open up dev
tools and here is that device toggle
toolbar so I could also hit command
shift M on my Mac computer but anywhere
that you're using Chrome and could
August let's click into the browser
screen and open up dev tools so I've
clicked this open here I have a few
options I have a responsive option so I
could see what this looks like at
various screen sizes by dragging it over
you also have a drop-down here with some
default devices like the Galaxy s5 the
pixel to excel to see what this looks
like at various screen sizes we have the
iPad pro here and you're also able to
adjust this from horizontal to vertical
sake
what that looks like when you flip that
device that's a little bit more dramatic
on a phone here so if you flip it you
get a completely different layouts you
can also again use this responsive mode
you can even edit what the devices are
that you want to showcase so here in the
dev tools I'm gonna pull this out and
going to hit edit and I have a bunch of
devices here you can add a custom device
you can add devices that aren't
currently in your drop-down by default
so if you want to test for example on
the iPhone 4 or if you want to test on
the Nexus 7 I will now have these inside
the drop-down when I next open it so
there they are
iPhone 4 and the Nexus 7 somewhere in
this drop-down right here so you can see
that that focal looks completely
different than that iPhone 4 and that's
important for you to know as a designer
we also have various break points here
that allow for you to just quickly
change between common sizes mobile
medium large tablet sizes laptop sizes
and you get a percentage based
visualization here that's scaled down to
fit inside of this browser screen so if
you want you can make this 100% view you
can make it a even larger of you if you
want to sort of zoom into that you can
make it 50% through fit in this area and
then you can see really large screens 4k
screens even even and if you don't have
a 4k screen you can still test on those
devices your design does change based on
the DPI of your screen and kind of is
determinate of whether you have a Retina
screen or non Retina screen
and that can also come into play where
you're deciding what images to send to
your users so if you want to test those
I have an example here with disco right
how this high-res image and now inside
of my dev tools I can actually test to
see that I'm sending a lower res image
with the lower resolution browsers in my
CSS I have a media query where I'm
sending a different image based on the
density of the screen so here if I have
a high density Retina screen I'm sending
a high resolution image if I don't it's
going to fall back to this low
resolution image so I can actually test
this with
a medium dpi his screen inside of my dev
tools and this becomes really useful if
you're sending a lot of large images and
you want to think about performance for
your users and for their devices and if
all of those aren't enough for you there
are some tools that you can use to
extend these capabilities and make
designing in the browser even easier one
of those tools is called this bug
created by Adam Argyle we're gonna fly
over to him to have him explain why it's
so useful for designers right now hmm
this page I like the layout I think
there's a lot going for it but it's
lacking some color don't you think well
let's have fun and and try it out let's
make some color in here with this bug
all I have to do is launch it in fact
I'm gonna scoot it down off of here so
that it's not conflicting with the
header and I'm gonna start with the
header it's just asking for a nice bold
color don't you think what do you think
of like a purple ooh pink a hot pink I'm
always done with hot pink all right I'm
actually settled that that's great okay
you can see our guides tool is trying to
help us make some alignment checks here
as we as we hover on other elements you
can get distance between them all right
but I'm also interested in changing this
image up here and I'm gonna drag in a
new one will I have an SVG icon here it
looks like this oh thanks for that that
did not work out very well but if I drop
it up here look at that I replaced it
that's kind of nice alright so what
about all of this these cards I feel
like they're a little tight I want to
check I want to check out their spacing
here so if I select I'm trying to select
the card element in here now I'm having
a little bit of a trouble because
there's so many elements in here look I
can actually select the elements inside
of here that's crazy town but in order
to get to these grid items I'm gonna
select the parent and use keyboard
navigation to help me get there someone
hit Enter which is gonna select the
first item as a child so I selected the
grid container I hit enter and I
selected the first one I hit command
shift E which is going to expand my
selection it's gonna find all the other
elements that match I've found them
there I still have the margin tool so if
I hit shift down twice I'm gonna add 20
pixels to the bottom and that's gonna
give me a little bit of spacing between
my rows super neat I can actually
continue using this multi selection of I
hit enter I'm gonna find that that each
of these cards had a wrap
element I hit enter again and I'm gonna
get the imaged container that's in the
upper part if I hit tab I'll find the
next element in the layer tree and I
want to change the alignment to these so
I'm gonna grab my flex box a line tool
I'm gonna hit left and right and find a
nice alignment and I'm gonna pick the
center and I'm gonna hit enter again and
we'll find that there's a span inside of
that container and I want to change the
text size of this I grabbed the text
tool I'm gonna hit up on the the
keyboard a few times here and I'm gonna
hit command down to change the font
weight and of course it needs some hot
pink so I'm gonna go over here to my
color picker and grab that hot pink from
up top close out and see what I did and
look at that we brought some color to
that page really pretty quick and we're
able to just sort of express ourselves
in a nice fast manner that was fun
I hope you enjoyed seeing a little bit
of taste of what vis bug can do for you
super cool thank you Adam I really love
using dev tools I use them every day for
designing directly in the browser for
prototyping for making decisions and I
find that these tools are just getting
better and better and better and that's
really exciting for me as somebody who
likes to design and build with a browser
what are your favorite dev tools are
there any that we missed in the show
that we didn't mention the tools that
you use every day I would love to hear
your thoughts please leave a comment
below and thanks for watching the show
we'll see you next time
save I just go
[Music]